superhot Stu finding characteristic is
immediately intriguing time only moves
forward when you act under these
conditions you methodically leave and
shoot your way through a series of
increasingly intricate levels which at
first don't seem connected in a
meaningful way
however superhot ultimately reveals its
true self a game designed to gradually
mess with your expectations of an area
once superhot establishes its ground
rules levels become more varied and
interesting forcing you to multitask and
orchestrate complex series of innumerous
despite the fact that there is no single
correct way to beat a given level your
methods do tend to stay the same unless
yourself imposing style challenges while
the core gameplay didn't evolve
drastically the story that drives it did
taking me along for a ride that I never
saw coming
in doing so it opened my eyes to
possibilities within that I never
considered superhot is a clever game
with deep hidden elements that require
committed and thorough examination
[Music]
you
[Music]